[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا في فلك الممنوع شابه
فرنسيه تحولت من المسيحيه الى الاسلام
قبلت ان تدلي بشهادتها لفرانس 24 لكنها
رفضت ان تظهر
خوفا من النتائج التي قد تترتب على ذلك في
محيط عملها اطلقنا عليها اسم ياسمين
لنهد لاه الا الله محد رسول
الله je me suis converti en 2002 2003
donc j'ai reu une ucation religieuse
chren trs pouss j'allais de fois par
semaine suivre les cours de catch et
vrai que dans ces cours un moment donn
est venu o je me posa des questions et
on m'a pas les rpes que
j'attends j'ai voir je connaissais un
peu dj la christien mais ensuite j'ai
appris ce qui l'islam et par la suite
j'ai pens que cit une suite logique des
choses donc voil il y a deux voies de
l'islam aujourd'hui et il faut que les
gens le comprennent c'est une religion
je pense de
l'origine avant que les hommes
l'instrument
la
justice c'est une religion tend le juste
milieu alors en france c'est trs
difficile d' accept en tant que
musulmane converti ou musulman tout
court par la soci ensuite en tant
converti dans le milieu dans mon
entourage moi a difficile aub parce que
voil c'est des choses que que les gens
autour de moi connaissent mais avec tout
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui les styp
les cl cit difficile pour eux de ne pas
avoir peur je pense que cta plus de la
peur et de l'e je suis musulmane mais
nche que j'ai des amis de partout et que
je tcep comme tu es mme tu nes pas
musul وفي فرنسا فرنسي اخر تحول الى
الاسلام عبد المالك الفرنسي وقبل ان يظهر
وجهه وه معنا عب سكايب رئيس جمعيه
الفرنسيون المسلمون الجد
عبد المالك هل تضمن فرنسا حريه المعتقد
لمن يريد ان يتحول الى
الاسلام بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله اهلا وسهلا اشكركم
على حضور في
ف بما يتلق سؤالك نعم معلوم
الحمدله نعم تضمن حريه المعتقد يعني انت
اليوم لا تشعر باي مضايقات لانك غيرت
دينك يعني في الحقيقه هناك الحريه في
فرنسا لكن معلوم بما
يتعلق لا سوسيتي المجتمع المجتمع شكرا
هناك
نعم
دغو يعني يعني على المستوى القانوني هناك
احترام لحريتك لحريه المعتقد لديك ولكن
على مستوى المجتمع هناك مضايقات من اي نوع
نعم هذا ماذون
وكثير كثير من المسلمين الجدود يشعرون ذلك
والمسلمون بشكل عام طب
لماذا
هذا هذا كما خلق الله يعني هذا تبعي يعني
من من يتبع
الحق فهذا ياتي بثمن نعم مالك اسمح لي
ساذهب الى واشنطن مع الاخ رشيد يعني عبد
المالك اليوم يعيش كما سمعت اخ رشيد في
فرنسا في مجتمع يضمن حريه المعتقد وفي
دوله تضمن حريه المعتقد اليوم انت هل
تستطيع ان تعود الى
المغرب لا استطيع ان اعود للمغرب و انا
تركت المغرب مرغما لا راغبا لاني احب
المغرب جدا لكن ضغوط المجتمع وضغوط
الحكومه ليس عندنا حريه عقيده ليس عندنا
حريه تغيير الدين وليس عندنا حتى حريه
التبشير الاخ عبد المالك يستطيع ان يبشر
ويدعو لدينه في فرنسا دون مشاكل وانا لا
استطيع ان اقوم بذلك حتى حين كنا نجتمع
للعباده كنا نجتمع في البيوت
ويداهم وتداهم قوات الامن وتعتقل البعض
منا وتستنبط وتعامل معامله سيئه البعض
الاخر
ليس هناك حريه معتقد في ال نص نص الفصل
السادس من الدستور المغربي يقول ان
الاسلام دين الدوله ولكن الدوله تضمن لكل
واحد حريه ممارسه شؤونه الدينيه هذا لا
يتيح لك ان ه هذا ليس صحيح هذه يتيح
الحريه الدينيه للفرنسي المتواجد في
المغرب ولانجليزي
وللامانه للمغاربه ان يتحولوا الى دين اخر
لا نستطيع ان نتزوج زواج مسيحي لا نستطيع
ان نسمي ابنائنا اسماء مسيحيه لا نستطيع
حتى ان نحصل على كتاب مقدس باللغه العربيه
في المغرب لا نستطيع اي شيء فنحن نعاني في
المغرب معاناه شديده واتحدث باسم الكثيرين
الالاف من المغاربه الذين اعتنق المسيحيه
في المغرب طيب يعني حضره الامام استمعت
الى الاخ رشيد هل تعتقد ان المشكله هي في
الاسلام
كدين لهذا يعاني كل من يغير
دينه ام المشكله عفوا اسمح لي ان اكمل الم
الدول انا ذكرت ان عندما الدين يختلط
بهويه سياسيه او هويه اثنيه بالطبع يغلب
تغلب الهويه عن تعاليم الدين عندما يكون
يكون الدين هو دين
مدني غجي سيفيل
ومكون اساسي من الهويه فال المساس بهذه
الهويه
كمس بالمنظومه
السياسيه فلابد انا اظن انه لابد من عمل
ثيولوجي فكري
ا ياتي من
علماء يتمتعون بحريه كامله ليخوضوا هذا
المجال لان الغالب في العالم الاسلامي
الان هو المنظومه السياسيه هي التي تملي
على كثير من العلماء كيف يفتون وكيف
يوجهون ونحن في عالم متعولي على كل حال
الناس من خلال الانترنت سيختارون الدين
الذين يختارون انا اظن ان الحجه بالحجه
والفكر بالفكر ا صحيح اما القمع فاما
القمع فهو يكثر الاتباع في الحقيقه نعرف
المسيحيه انها اهدت
وهذا ايض ايضا ربما القمع هو ما دفع ايضا
بالاخ رشيد انت قاسي جدا في برامجك فيما
يتعلق بالاسلام يعني تنتقد بشكل هجومي
كبير الديانه الاسلاميه هل هذا يعود لانك
منعت او حرمت من ممارسه معتقدك في
دولتك لا انا اميز بين الشيئين اميز بين
المسلم وبين العقيده فانا احب المسلمين
احب والدتي احب والدي احب مجتمعي احب كل
المسلمين عندي عائله ممتده احبهم جميعا
لكن معتقد انا قاسي معه لان هذا هذا معتقد
هذه فكره قد نغير افكارنا قد ننتقدها قد
نعيب هذه هذه ليست مشكله لان القران اعطى
لنفسه حق انتقاد المسيحيين ايضا قال لقد
كفر الذين قالوا ان الله هو المسيح ابن
مريم فكيف يحرمني من شيء ولكنك بنيت
رسالتك التبشيريه اخ رشيد على هجوم الهجوم
على الاسلام على انتقاد الاسلام نقد لاذع
يعني لما لا تكتفي بنشر التعاليم المسيحيه
فقط ولماذا لا يكتفي الاسلام بنشر تعاليم
الاسلام دون انتقاد المسيحيه واليهوديه
والاديان الاخرى طبعا كل كل تبشير وكل
مناداه معتقد تتضمن شقين شق ايجابي وهو
التبشير بالعقيده وشق سلبي هو
انتقاد المنظور المنافس لها او منظومات
المنافسه له لن تتمكن من ان تعود الى
بلادك يعني الناس التي تشاهد تعتبر انك
عدوا لها لانك تتحدث اليها بلهجه قاسيه
جدا كيف يمكنك ان تكسب هذا الجمهور اذا
كنت
هكذا اذا فهم الناس انني انتقد العقيده
واحبهم كاشخاص اعتقد سيفهمون اني لست ضدهم
ولست عدوهم العدو العدو نعم نعم وهم
ينتقدون ايضا عقيدتي واستطيع ان اشرب
فنجان شاي مع الشيخ الذي يجلس معك في
الاستديو دون اي مشكله اذا فهمنا ان
العقيده شيء والشخص شيء اخر مشكلتنا في
مجتمع لكن اخر شي وجهت وجهت رساله الى
براك اوباما تقول فيها ان تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه يجسد ديانه الاسلام يعني هذه
الطروحات كيف ستساعدك على على على كسب
احترام
المسلمين صحيح و وانا اكررها هنا ما الذي
فعلته داعش لم يفعله محمد بن عبد الله نفس
الشيء قطع الرؤوس والسبي وسبي النساء وكل
هذه الامور هي نفس الشيء هي تكرار لما حصل
منذ 1400 سنه فاذا اردنا ان نكون ان نكون
صريحين ف ينبغي ان نعزل انفسنا عن العقيده
العقيده شيء والناس اشخاص والاشخاص شيء
اخر فانا لا لا ادمج بين الاثنين من لديه
مشكله هو الذي يدمج بين الاثنين ويعتبر اي
انتقاد للعقيده هجوم عليه شخصي ولكن يا اخ
رشيد العقيده هي جزء من التركيبه
الاجتماعيه يعني هذا امر علمي والتركيبه
الثقافيه للمجتمعات كيف يمكن تل الشخص عن
عقيدته وتقول انا احترمك ولكنني اسب واشتم
عقيدتك يعني هذا امر ربما لا اسب لا اسب
ولا اشتم اختي ينبغي التمييز بين النقد
والسب والشتيمه لا استخدم اي مصطلحات غير
محترمه لا استخدم اي مصطلحات بدئه فالنقد
والمسلمون ينتقدون لقد اتهموا الانجيل
بالتحريف اتهمو باننا مشركون اتهمونا
باننا عباد صليب عبر التاريخ اتهمونا
باننا متل نعبد ثلاث الهه ولا احد قال لهم
انكم تكرهون المسيحيين بناء على انتقادكم
للعقيده فقاد العقيده به بهذا بهذا الكلام
انه عندما يقول القران انه الثالوت هو
عقيده المسيحيه لا يكذب في ذلك انما يعرض
حقيقه
ومعتقد وكما ذكرت هناك فرق بين بين النقد
والسب القران نفسه يذكر ولا تسب الذين
يدعون من دون الله يسب الله عدوا بغير علم
فالنقاش مطلوب والحوار مطلوب بل القران
مليء
بين مليء بالحوار مع الاخرين الا انه
ينبغي ان ان ان ان نتحاور فكريا من غير
اتهام والنقطه الثانيه انه ينبغي ان لا
انلا نختزل الاسلام في تجربته التاريخيه
بما في ذلك الزمن القراني فسيره ليست هي
الدين التجربه التاريخيه الرسول كان في
وضع ليس هو وضع المسيح ولا هو وضع موسى ف
الرساله واحده لكن التجربه التاريخيه كانت
مختلفه
تماما الظروف ظروف نشاه الاسلام ظروف نشاه
المسيحيه نعود الى موضوعنا انت اليوم تقول
ان المسلم اليوم يحق له ان يغير دينه ربما
لم يكن مسلما يوما من الايام كثير من
الناس المسلم على الهويه ولد ولد انا اقول
لك عندما اسمع بعض الناس يتكلمون عن عن
الله وعن الاسلام اقل لكم دينكم ولي دين
طيب دعنا نشاهد مع الاخ رشيد في فرنسا
ايضا تجربه غير اعتياديه جزائري عربي مسلم
تحول الى رجل دين مسيحي مبشر القص سعيد
اجيبه jus dit je suis le ch je suis la
vit et je suis la vie je l' pas pour une
blux bleu je l'ai pas accept pour de
l'argent je l'ai pas accept pour des
papiers je l'ai accept parce que bien sr
que je suis rejet depuis 25 ans de
certains je dirais mem de ma famille
bien sr que la vie n'est pas facile mais
si je suis
pers la bible me dit c'est cause de la
justice bien sr je suis pers bien sr
qu'on est rejet on est des chiens on
nous rej on nous crache dessus mais je
suis fier d'en jus je suis pas j'aime
jus j'ai accept jus et la doctrine
coranique a besoin d'une vit r si vous
vous voulez des mosques en france nous
voulons desis en arabie saoudite si vous
acceptez que des francais deviennent
musulmans il faut accepter que des
musulmans acceptent jus pas le
christianisme pas l'occident jus il est
pas all la maison blanche sonre c'est
pas obama vous avez pas le choix et vous
nz pas le choix nous sommes des milli
nous sommes milli aujourd'hui accept
jus trouver des prex pour nous dire que
nous avons subi un lavage de cerveau ou
alors que finalement on s'est fait
acheter par des personnes qui viennent
de outre atlantique je vous le dis et je
vous le redis vous comme ces millions de
personnes qui nous regardent je me suis
pas converti pour un visa je suis pas
comme certains hypocrites qui
aujourd'hui je dirais en france dball le
tapis rouge avec l'arabie saoudite je ne
suis pas achet par des pet dollars
saoudien allez laver votre cur allez
laver
vre ilu
trans' malr tout ce que vous jus il est
cap حضره الامام طارق ابرو ما رايك هل
تقبل هذا الشخص هذا مسلم سابقا كان مسلما
ولد مسلما وهو اليوم مبشر بالمسيحيه رجل
دين مسيحي هل
تقبل يعني يعني المسلمون والسلطات
الاسلاميه يعني التي تمثل الاسلام لا تحكم
على هذا
الرجل السياسه منطقها منطقها انا اتكلم
باسم الدين انا لا امثل لا دوله ولا
السعوديه وكن انت تقول
لاتباع ان يتركوا من يترك الاسلام بحاله
انا ذكرت مبدا من اراد ان يختار المسيحيه
فله ذلك ومن اراد ان يختار الاسلام فله
ذلك مع اعتقادي ان الاسلام هو حق بالطبع
ولكن لا يمكن ان تكره انسان ان ان تدخل في
قلبه عقيده لا يرضاها ا من المستحيل يعني
يعني انت تقبل هذا الرجل اذا الزمت الناس
بعقيده لا يرضون ستكثر المنافقين في
المجتمع ام ما مصلحه امه فيها منافقين لا
يرضون هذا الدين طيب اخ رشيد يعني هل
تعرضت لغسل الدماغ بعض الناس تقول بان من
يتحول الى اديان اخرى طبعا غير غير الدين
الذي ولد عليه انه يطبق ربما اجندات غربيه
ان هناك خطه ربما لتفكيك المجتمعات
الاسلاميه والعربيه يعني هذا امر ايضا تم
الحديث عنه في العديد من المناسبات وكتب
عنه كثيرا يعني فهل تعتقد انك ضمن هذا
الاطار اولا نظريه المؤامره تجري فينا
مجرى الدماء فقد تعلمنا ان نرمي همومنا
ومشاكلنا على غيرنا لم نتعلم تحمل
المسؤوليه لم يغسل دماغي اي شخص بالعكس
فانا ولدت في اسره مسلمه ولا يوجد اي شيء
شيء يغريني بان اتعرض لكل المشاكل التي
تعرضت لها في حياتي مقابل يعني اي شيء اخر
لا توجد اموال ولا توجد اي شيء ولا غسيل
دماغي يعوض الضرر النفسي والضرر المادي
الذي تعرت له انا انا لا استطيع ان ادخل
بلدي مسقط راسي حيث تربيت حيث عشت لمده 32
سنه لا استطيع ان ادخل هذا البلد فهذه
معاناه لا يمكن ان يعوضها اي شيء متى
نتوقف عن مهاجمه الشخص ونناقش بادب
واحترام عوض الهجوم على الاشخاص انهم
مغسول دماغ شهاده اخرى اخ رشيد لشاب هنغري
كان يدعى ملوش واصبح اسمه احمد كيف اسلمت
في هنغاريا شاهدوا
معنا اسمي مكلوش هذا اسم مجري
وحبيت ان يكون اسمي كمان اسم اسلامي اسم
مسلم اخترت اسم احمد كل مسيحي بالاسم بس
مثل اكثر الناس عندنا في المجر انا مسلم
منذ عام 2004 الحمد لله كان في كتاب مكتوب
الشهاده بحروف اللاتينيه اشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا رسول الله وقلت
خلاص لو اريد اكون مسلم لازم اقول هذه
الكلمه وقلت الكلمه في ديانات ديانه
الثانيه ما يقبل الاكل لكن الاسلام مفهوم
دين صافي
و فهم بعقلي وجاء الايمان لقلبي يقول الله
سبحانه وتعالى في القران الكريم فمن شاء
فليؤمن ومن شاء فليكفر وانا اعتقد
انه في حريه يعني بالاسف المجتمع في المجر
المجتمع جاهله يعني ما يعرف شيء عن
الاسلام ويصورون ان الاسلام
دين دين حق العنف ودين هاب
ودين الظلم وهكذا
ولما عرفوا ان مسلم احيانا نحسن المضايقات
من الناس مثلا يقولوا ها انت مسلم انت
هتفجر نفسك
وهكذا يعني الحركات مثل الداعش وحركات
الارهابيه والحركات المتطرف المتطرفه
بعيدين عن الاسلام بعيدين من كل البعد في
المجتمعات الاوروبيه وتحديدا في فرنسا
صعود لموجه الفرنسيين الذين يعتنقون
الاسلام حوال 4000 فرنسي يشرون اسلامهم
سنويا حضره الامام طارق اوبرو هل تؤثر
العنصريه في المجتمع الفرنسي او
الاسلاموفوبيا على حريه المعتقد لا اظن
نحن في مجتمعات مفتوحه كما يقول كارل
بوبر الحريه
مكفوله في ال ستور ولو ان في في المجتمع
تكون بعض الموانع وبع نعم كما قال هذا
الشاب يعني قال انه تعرض لمضايقات هذه
المضايقات بعضها مرده الى العنصريه وبعضها
مرده الى الخوف و والجهل بالدين وبعضها رد
الى تصرفات المسلمين الذي يشين بالاسلام
الذي اريد ان انبه اليه ان الدخول في دين
جديد لا ينبغي ان يكون ا
مصاحبا بالحقد على الدين القديم لان الدين
والحقد والايمان والحقد لا يلتقيان فيما
اعتقد هل استطيع ان اسال اخ رشيد انت حاقد
على دينك القديم حاقد على
الاسلام انا لست حاقد لان الاسلام ليس
بشخص حتى احقد عليه هو مجرد مجموعه
معتقدات انا ارفضها الان
واراها يعني ضد الانسانيه وضد تعلم
الكراهيه وتربينا على استمعت الى هذه
الشهاده للشاب الهنجري هو شاب مسالم لا
يحرض على ضد الانسانيه لا يحرض على اي شيء
بالعكس يتعرض للاضطهاد بسبب اسلامه يعني
هو يشاركك نفس التجربه التي
تعيشها ليتي ليتني اتعرض الى الاضطهاد
الذي يتعرض اليه في بلدي المغرب ليتني
اتعرض لنفس الاضطهاد هذه مضايقات اجتماعيه
مرجعها الى الجهل احيانا والى بعض الناس
لكن ليست قاعده عامه نحن عندنا القاعده هي
الاضطهاد والاستثناء هو ان تجد بعض الناس
متفهمين لكن خليني افرق بين شيئين والدتي
ايضا انسانه مسالمه ليس المسلم هو الاسلام
المسلم قد يختار بعض المعتقدات والدتي قد
تختار الصلاه المطلوب اخ رشيد ما المطلوب
ما المطلوب لكي تعود انت الىى الى المغرب
ما الذي تطلبه من السلطات
المغربيه المطلوب هو ان نعطي الناس حريه
الع عقيده نعطيهم الحق في اختيار ما شاءوا
ونضع قوانين تنظيميه لهذه المساله لاننا
نضيع الكثير من الموارد ونضيع حتى الشباب
انا اعرف العشرات من الشباب شخصيا الذين
تركوا المغرب بسبب هذا الامر وهناك الالاف
الذين يراسلوني من كل العالم العربي بسبب
هذا الامر لو فتحوا المجال قلت هناك 4000
سنويا في فرنسا لو فتحوا المجال في
بلداننا
بكميه الناس الذين تركوا الاسلام سرا
واتبعوا مذاهب اخرى من بينها المسيحيه
حضره الامام هل توافق على هذه
الاقوال ول فميلي ديني ان الحريه ينبغي ان
تكون مكفوله للناس وان الافكار تقارع
بالافكار والمعتقدات
تتناقش بالمعتقدات
الشعر بالشعر والسجع بالسجع والنثر بالنثر
نعم قل هاتوا برهانكم كنتم صادقين القران
لا يحبذ هذا الاعتقاد الاعي انا وجدنا
اباءنا على امه وان على اثارهم مهتدون
قوللو كان ابائكم لا يعقلون شيئا ولا
يهتدون القران ينوه بالفكر
والنظر بل المسلمون في القرون الوسطى
كانوا انشاوا علم الخلافيات كانوا يبحثون
عن اليهودي والنصراني ليتنا قشون مع معهم
يعني لابد من الحوار ثقافه الحوار
س نختصر الان لان الوقت لم يعد كافيا
سنذهب الى مشاركات المشاهدين على فيسبوك
اخترت سؤالا من مصر لمحمد عماد يوسف لا
ادري ان كنا نستطيع ان نشاهد السؤال نعم
نشاهده اذا يقول انا مع حريه اختيار
المعتقد بشكل مطلق وانا من حقي اني اغير
ديني في اي وقت وزي ما انا عايز ولكن
للاسف الواقع في مصر اللي بيغير دينه مهما
كان دينه ايه والدين اللي بغير لي هي انه
حياته هتدمر بكل الاشكال انا كمان بتمنى
اني اتزوج من دين مختلف للاسف الكنيسه
والازهر عائق امام ده اذا اخ رشيد وحضره
الامام هذا الشاب المصري يعتبر ان المشكله
ليست فقط الاسلام اخ رشيد المشكله ايضا في
الكنيسه الكنيسه ايضا في مصر مثلا لا تقبل
من يخرج عنها ما رايكم تفضل سيد
طارق منظومات بشريه يعتريها ما يعتري
البشر انثروبولوجيه وعقليه مؤسسات
ومنظومات
سياسيه واقع الناس هذا هو واقعهم الدول
الاسلاميه اغلبها دول لا تعرف الحريه
اصلا مفهوم الحريه عندنا لا في المعتقد
ولا في حتى في الفكر
ولا يعني شبه شبه منعدمه نحن راينا
الانتخابات في في في عنما تنتج نتيجه لا
ترضي بعض الناس يحدثون
انقلابات هناك انحطاط حضاري اثر سلبا على
على على على المنظومه الدينيه طيب اخ رشيد
ما
رايك بالنسبه ل الكنيسه لا تقتل احدا
واعرف الكثير من المسيحيين الذين ايضا
حولوا الى اديان او تركوا المسيحيه ولم
تقتلهم الكنيسه لا في مصر ولا في غير مصر
بالنسبه لقضيه الزواج هي قضيه
الكن ولكن اخ رشيد يعني هناك العديد من
الحالات الاجتماعيه التي سمعنا عنها ايضا
عن اقبات مصر اقبات تحولوا الى دين اخر
وتعرضوا للنبذ من الكنيسه وملاحقات من
عائلتهم وتهديد بالقتل يعني هذا امر
اجتماعي يحصل في كل في كل المجتمعات
العربيه ولدى كل الطوائف ليس فقط لدى
الاسلام و وينبغي هنا ان نفرق بين تصرفات
الناس المعزوله عن الدين وبين التصرفات
المبنيه على الدين المسيح سمح ليهو ان
يخونه لا لا المسيح طيب طيب لحظه المسيح
سمح ليهوذا ان يخونه بينما محمد امتلك تسع
سيوف و والعباره المشهوره على لسان اصحابه
ان اضرب عنقه يا رسول الله المسيحيين ايضا
قاموا بحروب صليبيه يا اخ رشيد يعني انا
انا احاول فقط ان اقول انا اعود هل قام
المسيح بالحروب الصليبيه لم تمكنوا الظروف
من ذلك والا لقد طلب من اتباعه اسمح لي
اسمح لي يا سي اسمح ليدخل الان اخ رشيد
طلب من اتباعه باحضار السيوف لكن الامور
كانت الروي اخ رشيد وح التاريخيه مختلفه
تماما النقاش في فلك الممنوع لا نهايه لش
النقاش في فلك الممنوع لا نهايه له نترك
لك ولك ولكل من يشاهدنا حريه التفكير
وحريه الاختيار فما رايكم شاركونا بارائكم
وتعليقاتكم على صفحتنا على فيسبوك وعلى
هاشتاج ممنوع 24 في فلك الممنوع مع في
حلقه جديده وموضوع جديد كل خميس عند
الرابعه وعش دقائق بتوقيت باريس وطبعا على
شاشه فرانس 24 و على fr.com
[موسيقى]
تحياتي